[Musique]
les britanno colombiens devront répondre
par un vote postal à deux questions
d'ici le 30 novembre ils devront d'abord
dire s'il préfère garder ou abandonner
le système actuel c'est à dire le
scrutin uninominal à un tour
ensuite ils devront indiquer leur
préférence pour l'un des trois modèles
suivants une représentation
proportionnelle à deux députés où chaque
partie présente deux candidats le parti
en tête qu'un dray le premier siège
alors que le deuxième serait attribuée
en fonction des résultats à l'échelle de
la province
une représentation proportionnelle mixte
qui permettrait aux électeurs de voter
pour un candidat au niveau régional et
pour un parti au niveau provincial
un modèle de représentation différent
selon que vous êtes en milieu rural où
ce serait proportionnelle ou en milieu
urbain où on classerait les candidats en
ordre de préférence
les choix plutôt complexe de l'avis des
observateurs pour changer le système
électoral il faudra plus de 50% des voix
en faveur de la représentation
proportionnelle
c'est la troisième fois que les
électeurs de la province se prononcent
par référendum sur une réforme du mode
de scrutin
les deux premières tentatives s'étaient
soldées par le statu quo